all right uh there's something very
interesting happening within the
republican party as we've talked about
before and that is this growing civil
war not only between
anti-trump and pro-trump republicans but
as i've said before now a couple of
times between
formerly pro-trump republicans and
pro-trump republicans and donald trump
has now shown us
the pinnacle
of his vindictive nature his rage at
anyone who might levy even the mildest
criticism against him
he has completely turned on republican
senator lindsey graham now let's kind of
build up to it the context here
is that donald trump has now floated
that he might pardon
january 6th rioters if he
becomes president again
in 2024
so here is trump saying that for the
first time at his rally in conroe texas
over the weekend here's a reminder so
many people have been asking me about it
if i run and if i win
we will treat those people from january
6 fairly we will treat them fairly
and if it requires pardons we will give
them pardons because they are being
treated so
unfairly
so after that which is a dangerous
outrageous statement after that
republican senator lindsey graham
appeared in a tv interview lindsey
graham is a long time friend of trump's
lindsey graham is a guy who played golf
with trump regularly during the
presidency uh
got along you know what to whatever
degree trump has friends lindsey graham
would be considered or would have been
considered a friend of donald trump and
lindsey graham says it's completely
inappropriate to do that and it seems
like it sort of might be encouraging the
exact type of violent destruction of uh
of the capital that we saw on january 6.
here is lindsay
responding to donald trump talking about
pardons pardons do you agree
yeah
no i don't want to send any signal uh
that it was okay to defile the capital
there are other groups with causes that
may want to go down the violent path
that these people get pardoned but isn't
that a dangerous thing to say
yeah well i think it's inappropriate i
don't want to reinforce that defiling
the capital was okay okay so trump is
asked about this during a news max
interview yesterday with rob schmidt
and he completely turns on lindsey
graham
he calls lindsey graham a rhino meaning
a republican in name only and you really
see here
this disloyal
vindictive trump that is the guy we know
exists obviously but here it's coming up
with a guy who was in theory a friend of
donald trump's take a look
you talked about the potential if it's
appropriate of pardoning some of the
january 6th
lindsey graham said a couple days later
he thinks that's inappropriate what do
you think well lindsey graham's wrong
i mean lindsay's a nice guy but he's a
rhino
lindsay's wrong
look
this is really the kind of bottom of the
barrel
disloyal trump there's no loyalty for
trump his best friends again to the
extent he has real friends and i don't
know if he does trump's relationships
with people including his own family are
very very strange his friends are
immediately enemies if they say just one
wrong thing graham is just the latest
victim here
trump going on to talk about how many of
the writers
are not even guilty uh he says that
they're patriots some of them they're
not guilty of crimes
and says lindsey graham doesn't know
what the hell he's talking about and
this this is notable for a couple of
reasons which we'll talk about in a
moment
and some of these people are not guilty
many of these people are not guilty what
they've done to to
these and in many cases patriots their
soldiers their policemen what they've
done to them compared to what they've
done to the other side now by the way
the fact that sometimes they're soldiers
and policemen
that's an aggravating factor these these
are folks that we should be saying
wow
if soldiers and policemen are so deluded
that they're doing this it's not even
about criminality we should be
questioning whether they should be
soldiers and policemen for trump it's oh
but i mean they're soldiers and
policemen they just shouldn't even be
charged i guess
you know you have to have equal justice
and this is an equal
so i would absolutely be prepared and
lindsey graham doesn't know what the
hell he's talking about if he says that
because you have to have equal justice
it's very very unfair what's happened to
this group of people now if you claim to
be for law and order and due process how
can you say someone is not guilty before
their case has even been adjudicated by
the legal system
they don't care about any of their
principles how many times have i said
this now they're about law and order
when it's convenient
they're about due process
when it's convenient
prisons and jails are places where we
don't have to concern ourselves with
conditions
when it's not their people who are there
now all of a sudden trump and others are
saying the conditions in in jail that
these people are being held in are
terrible we've been talking about that
for decades we've been talking about it
for decades and then the attacks on uh
um
rather the issue of sentences comes up
again here and trump saying uh restating
that he is is up for giving pardons some
of them are being treated very unfairly
yeah i would absolutely
give them a pardon the punishment things
don't work out fairly punishments are
out of proportion to the crime out of
proportion like 20 times out of
proportion yeah i mean if they're if if
they're patriots the way donald trump
said
why on earth would they get any
punishment so this is extraordinarily
dangerous and this is a hallmark
of the
fascist dictator the dictator wannabe
the authoritarian and the autocrat right
wherever you want on that scale uh
friend of the show former guest fellow
argentinian federico finkelstein has
been tweeting a lot about this
when
law and order don't work for you
what authoritarians and fascist
dictators do is they impose their will
instead of law and order and that's what
trump is saying here we are you've got
to do everything right
you can come to the country but you got
to do it legally you call everything
just legally the way the law says well
here we have people who are being
subjected to what the law says no no no
no
my will that these are patriots is what
now matters and i will pardon them if
given the opportunity it doesn't even
matter whether he really would pardon
them
uh we it's impossible to know that at
this point in time one last clip from
this interview here is the reporter i
mean this this guy should he should
really be blushing from the this
interview here's the reporter rob
schmidt
uh sort of praying at the altar of trump
and saying you know
you could be having such a great life
but instead you want to be president
again
it's it's truly unbelievable that has
got to do stuff as much as you do i mean
most people by your age just want to
relax you want to go back in what a hero
instead of just relaxing trump wants to
go back in war zone
i mean you're flirting with it right now
you're not going to announce and i
understand that but to go back into
there i think people would have to say
you're crazy very simple reason
we have a great country that's going to
hell
and it's going to hell very fast and
we're not going to have a country left
and this is the same rhetoric from 2016.
we don't we're not going to have a
country great job i did more than most
presidents would do in 30 years
between the taxes more damage right the
regulations and the business and
everything else he did the business i
mean think about how meaningless these
things are he did the taxes okay yes
there was a tax bill passed he did the
regulations of no meaning
um and he did the business then i got we
got hit with the covid right from china
and they got to pay something for that
they're going to pay something
nobody could afford you know it's
probably 60 trillion dollars worldwide
anyway i won't subject you to more of it
but a truly delusional interview showing
us the vindictive nature of trump the
childish and jealous nature of trump
and also his complete and total
willingness
to do absolutely anything
in complete abandonment of his stated
principles in this case law order and
due process
when it doesn't work out the way he
wants it to work out extremely dangerous
stuff
i want to introduce you to emmy the
world's first instant ramen that is low
carb high protein and 100
plant based each serving of imi
is packed with 21 grams of protein
19 grams of fiber has only five net
carbs works for keto diets and 35
percent less sodium than traditional
ramen brands i've been making it at home
just like any instant ramen it's ready
in just a few minutes you can use the
microwave you can use the stovetop you
really can't beat the convenience but
with imme you can feel good about the
ramen you're eating because of all the
fiber the lower sodium and it is
plant-based which i love even though i'm
not vegan or vegetarian but the best
part is
it's so well packaged it comes in
flavors like spicy beef
tom yum shrimp
black garlic chicken the taste and the
quality of the ingredients really sets
it apart from any other instant ramen
i've had and emmy is giving my audience
five dollars off a variety pack when you
go to emmyeats.com
pacman and use the coupon code pacman
the link is down below